Google最近推出了一個嚇死人的功能Google AI模式
這個功能直接把AI跟瀏覽網路整合在一起
讓你在用Google的同時也同時用到Gemini
重點是他隱藏了很多沒有說的功能
而這些功能每個幾乎都能夠改變你使用網路的習慣
難道支配我們這麽久的SEO生態就快要被AI SEO取代了嗎
嗨各位又是我AJ
Google在2025年年終的時候宣布了一件大事
就是他們未來要把AI跟網路瀏覽甚至是Google Chrome瀏覽器整併在一起
同一時間他們也推出了AI MODE這個功能
然後就沒有然後了
這個功能就這樣過去了半年
正當我們逐漸遺忘他的時候
10月初Google一個猝不及防直接開放的繁體中文AI MODE
並且全面更新他的UI界面
真的是 要馬安靜 要馬all in
Google真的是好樣的 給你個讚
今天我們測試出了幾個AI mode相當出彩的隱藏功能跟應用
老話一句都是不用錢的 在正式開始之前呢
一樣來一個好康分享
YouTube官方以及泛科學院目前正式推出全台唯二
可以拿到YouTube learning的聯名證書AI課程
一門是專門為國小高年級到國中生設計的少年們的AI簡報影音大作戰
讓同學們一步步完成自我介紹
簡報講稿 影音作品
第二門課則是面向高中生大學生還有上班族的AI神隊友
從prompt指令
deep research
Canvas編輯到NotebookLM的筆記整合
讓你真正學會
如何用Gemini實戰 這兩門課完全免費開放
只要完成課程並且通過線上測驗
你就能夠拿到正式的YouTube Learning聯名證書
趕快點選影片的介紹連結
開啟你的AI學習新紀元吧
那AI mode在哪里呢
你現在打開這個Google瀏覽器
然後一個空白的分頁
然後沒有
所以你要去哪里找呢
你要直接去Google首頁你現在就會看到這個AI模式
所以在這個模式之下你就可以去啟用你的AI模式
點一下會長這個樣子
其實我覺得他就像是一個重新設計的Google搜尋的首頁
所以我覺得他這個應該還是在做某種程度上在做AB測試
那你就可以提出一個問題給他比如說
我要怎麽樣在自己家里做麻油雞
你也可以用麥克風輸入你也可以放圖片上去給他做
就像你在用Gemini一樣然後你問他
他就有一些漂亮的動畫
好了就告訴你啊
做麻油雞很簡單
旁邊有一些參考資料
然後這些網址點下去
就會說這個東西是在哪里出現的
那這樣的結果你滿意嗎
這就就那樣啊
他也可以去做到這樣的一個公開分享鏈接
把你的這個AI對話這個記錄就像是Gemini一樣 那AI摘要跟AI模式說實話了
生成出來的結果我們自己看我覺得是差不多差不多
那唯一一個差別就是
我在AI摘要裡面
如果我想要追問他一個問題的時候 不好意思他就沒有辦法追問
如果你在AI模式之下 那你有任何的問題 比如說我家只有一個電鍋
該怎麽煮
你就可以根據你的需求
然後他會去思考
然後再次的快速搜尋
再次的給你這個結果
那另外講到AI搜尋
其實啊另外一個非常有名的這個AI搜尋的功能叫perplexity
那perplexity我自己用起來的感覺是
它會更喜歡給我一點比較偏完整文章的一個說明文件的感覺
雖然說大概只有一頁左右 其實也是非常快速的這個生成
對你來說你只要熟悉一個你自己習慣的我覺得沒有好壞
透過AI幫你搜尋網路在那個浪潮里面 都還可以獲得蠻不錯的這個成果
那找到這個地方AImode就結束了 對結束了
你說不對 AImode厲害的地方其實你必須要切換成英文版的AImode
他才會有更多
目前已經有開放的一些功能
那我們就先來快速的把我們的這個界面 先快速的切換成英文的模式
首先你可以在管理的賬戶里面找到個人資訊
然後我們新增一個語言叫做English
他是United state English
然後把它頂上去
好那現在整個界面就會變成英文啦
好那我們現在切換到了英文模式 那在這個狀態之下的AImode
當然他就只能聽得懂英文
你就會把用中文去下指令
所以我們準備了一個測試提示詞 假設我們下個禮拜要飛東京
然後這個我們要去找一些不錯喝酒的地方哎show me some place interesting
然後把它送出去
你看到AImode它生成的這些內容里面 就會包含各種各式各樣的這些
多元的這樣的一個資料呈現
這些內容點進去之後
他會直接帶這個Google map的這個地標資料出來 因為他是對話形式
所以你就可以直接按下面這個share public link
你就可以直接copy link直接分享給你的朋友
然後大家就可以來討論我們要去哪間店喝酒
但是下面他記得還會出現一個東西叫做explore and create沒錯
他也把Gemini網頁的里面的那個Canva畫布模式整理過來的
所以這一份報告你可以直接create Canvas
這樣子就問有沒有像是在Gemini里面去做這樣的一個操作呢
哦
所以他會慢慢的在AImode里面把其他成品里面 他覺得好用實用的工具
慢慢的把它
內化進來
我覺得這個是Google目前看起來野心非常非常大的
就是他等於是要重新打造我們跟搜尋引擎的這樣的一個互動的方式
所以你看他一次就啟動了24個search找到了161個網站
然後從google map拿到資料最終他幫我做成了一份canvas的這樣的一個報告
所以這一切一切按一下就好了
那這個完整的報告
我覺得比較有趣的地方是他會去針對比如說
我們下個禮拜 所以他也會知道下個禮拜哦
這個是10月20-26 那一周 然後去查這些資料所以這里面的這些表演啦
活動啦
餐廳啦 基本上都是在那一段時間里面有營業的這些服務 什麽的
就是他自己在選餐廳的時候
我覺得這個部分是有過大腦了然後再給你一份報告
所以我覺得這個東西的參考價值其實還蠻高的
生成完畢之後呢
我們還是可以再按一下這個分享然後用public link的形式哦分享出去
那你一樣就可以看到
打開之後的這個結果一樣是用canvas的這個形式去作那個呈現
那當然這樣的一個模式
其實就會讓我們想起像是這個Gemini那里面的那個叫做deep research的功能
深度資料查找 AImode里面呢這個功能它叫做deep search就是深度搜索
所以他會使用像是deep research這樣的功能
但是我覺得其實某種程度上應該同一個東西
到時候名字可能會統一吧
不知道 反正總之我可以在這個地方比如說
我一晚上大概要規劃準備多少錢
所以他會思考
然後根據這些資料
然後再重新的去修正報告 所以他就幫你去訂正這些內容
去做這樣的一個全盤的修正
所以我覺得有AI在你旁邊陪著你一起搜索這件事情
之後應該會變成一個主流
講到這個地方你一定很好奇就是我都找到了餐廳
那可不可以直接訂位
比如說我們開一個新的
然後這一次我們回到了台灣 跟他說我想要這個
找一個晚餐的餐廳我們三個要一起吃飯 這個禮拜五晚上6點台北101附近
拉麵 BBQ 等等這些東西 他就會幫你列出這些東西來
那你說這找到東西好像也沒有什麽差別
但是你就錯了 這時候有一個隱藏功能
在search lab里面有一個新的功能叫做agent capabilities in AImode 那記得要把這個模式
打開然後try it out打開完畢之後同樣的這個指令然後我們再次送出
所以各位可以看到開了agent mode之後 AI會幫你做到更多
他會去幫你找這些餐廳然後還幫你列出餐廳里面可以訂位的時間
所以如果你要訂位 現在你就簡單的點一下
他就會直接跳 原本就是google map上面接的這個這個應該是那個in line
好的 這個線上定位的平台
你只要把你的這些資料好
確認沒問題
你按一下reserve 就可以完成定位了
好所以這個agentic capabilities in AImode目前說實話只能訂餐廳
但是官方其實有提到就說未來他們也希望能夠做到一些像比如說訂票啦
那我猜所有能訂的他應該都會想一起做進去
訂票訂房 我覺得這個應該一兩年內應該就有機會了
好接下來呢我們換到了手機界面來操作 那你去安裝Google的官方APP
然後根據我們自己的經驗 變化很大 但總之想辦法把所有的界面都
改成英文
把手機的界面
手機的地區
然後你的這個google的這個賬號
然後你就會看到像現在這樣子上面會出現AI mode
那出現AImode之後呢
你就可以很簡單的給他打一個關鍵字叫做 Nike jacket
好 送出哦
他就會找到一些Nike jacket
比如說我覺得哦這個好像看起來不錯 點他一下
你就會看到一個功能叫做try it on 然後你就可以點這個try it on好
接下來你會看到這個try it on的功能
他就是一個之前在Google發表會上面有做的一個就是線上穿衣的這個Demo
那你就可以這邊按get started
好這邊他會要求你提供一些你的這個照片
那這邊有一個你要有全身的照片
只有你一個人的照片 然後亮度要OK的
然後手不要放在這個衣服里面 那你就可以upload photo
比如說
我這邊就可以傳一張我的這個照片 但這些照片這樣照片其實不太好
因為我手有點遮住 那會發生什麽事呢
好如果可以應該放你的全身
然後手要放在外面的這個照片 但是剛好最近沒有這種照片
我們就來做這樣一個照片測試看看
你就看他說
我臉就會被合到這件衣服上面去
做這樣的一個虛擬試穿的這個動作
所以未來我相信會有非常非常多
基於這些文字也好圖片也好影片也好的各種各式各樣的這些AI生成這些功能
會開始從頭的去打造我們跟機器之間的這個互動的關系
那根據我們的實測呢
你傳上去之後的你的照片他就會存在那個地方
你下一次要試穿的時候
他就會自動幫你把你舊的那個照片拉出來然後重新再幫你合一張上去
你看這就變成了一張我穿紅色帽t的這個照片啦
以上就是我們今天這一集的影片內容
我們帶領大家圍繞著AImode這個嶄新的功能
等你看到這只影片的時候可能又發生了一些變動 所以保持好奇心
在這波AI的這個浪潮里面
然後去勇於嘗試各種各式各樣的這些新的工具
那我們的影片就到這個地方
下一次影片再見嘍拜拜